aquí tenemos una máquina con dulces de
varios colores pero en esta ocasión nos
vamos a fijar en los dulces de color
amarillo digamos que sabemos que la
proporción de dulces amarillos que hay
aquí es p
este es el parámetro de la población
también vamos a decir que el 60% de los
dulces son de color amarillo o el 0.6 de
los dulces son de color amarillo
repasemos algunas de las cosas que hemos
visto con anterioridad definimos nuestra
variable aleatoria de brno link como ye
mayúscula es igual a uno cuando sale
aleatoriamente de la máquina un dulce
amarillo y es igual a 0 cuando sale un
dulce de cualquier otro color que no es
amarillo en vídeos anteriores aprendimos
cosas interesantes sobre esta variable
aleatoria de werniul y conocemos su
media que es igual a la proporción de
los dulces amarillos que hay aquí así
que esto es igual a p que a su vez es
igual a 0.6 también conocemos la
desviación estándar de esta variable
aleatoria de bernouilli es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de x
1 - p esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de punto 6 por punto 4 seguimos con el
repaso ahora vamos a definir una nueva
variable aleatoria x que es igual a la
suma de 10 ejecuciones independientes de
allí ya hemos visto variables
independientes como ésta antes esta es
una variable aleatoria binomial y que
sabemos de su media y desviación
estándar en vídeos anteriores vimos que
la media de esta variable aleatoria
binomial va a ser igual a n por la media
de cada una de las ejecuciones de esta
variable de bernal y esto es n por p que
en este caso es igual a 10 el número de
ejecuciones por p qué es 0.6 esto tiene
sentido porque si el 60% de los dulces
de aquí son amarillos y hacemos 10
ejecuciones es decir tomamos un dulce de
esta máquina vemos su color y lo
regresamos a la máquina y hacemos lo
mismo 10 veces podemos esperar que 6 de
los dulces sean amarillos puede que no
siempre tengamos 6 dulces amarillos
es lo que esperaríamos la desviación
estándar es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
n por p por 1
simplemente agregamos una n dentro del
radical y en este caso particular
tenemos 10 por 0.6 por 0.4 y calculamos
la raíz cuadrada del resultado todo esto
es un repaso de cosas que ya hemos visto
antes si algo de esto no les es familiar
los invito a que revisen los vídeos que
tenemos en caracas de mí sobre variables
aleatorias de bernouilli y variables
aleatorias binomial es lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo será pensar en la
distribución muestral y será la
distribución muestral para la
estadística conocida como la proporción
muestral de la cual hablamos cuando
presentamos el concepto de distribución
muestral vamos a separar lo que
repasamos y ahora vamos a tomar muestras
de 10 dulces y son muestras de 10 veces
porque quiero que coincidan con esta
variable aleatoria tomamos muestras de
10 dulces y calculamos la proporción de
dulces amarillos a esto le llamamos
de la muestra a qué es esto equivalente
podemos decir que es equivalente a la
variable aleatoria x pues quiero contar
el número de dulces amarillos y después
vamos a dividirlo entre el tamaño de la
muestra en este caso es x dividida entre
10 y quizá estén pensando en que x es la
suma de 10 ejecuciones independientes y
para que sean independientes no podemos
tomar 10 dulces directamente debemos
tomar uno por uno y devolverlos a la
máquina cada vez para que sean
verdaderamente independientes pero
recuerden que tenemos la regla del 10%
que nos dice que si una muestra es menor
o igual al 10% de la población
podríamos tratar a cada uno de los
dulces en este caso de forma
independiente imaginemos que aquí
tenemos 10.000 dulces así que podemos
considerar que debido a la regla del 10%
la extracción de dulces en cada muestra
son sucesos independientes una vez
considerado esto podemos hacer esta
afirmación digamos que para nuestra
primera muestra la proporción de la
muestra es
0.3 tres de los diez dulces resultaron
ser amarillos después tomamos otra
muestra y encontramos que la proporción
de la muestra ahora es igual a 7 de 10
seguimos haciendo esto y los resultados
los vamos a poner en una gráfica de
puntos más o menos así tenemos todos los
resultados posibles 0 de 10 1 de 10 2 de
10 3 4 5
vamos por la mitad 6 7 8 9 y 10 y
colocamos los resultados de la
proporción de cada muestra que tomamos
aquí ponemos la primera que fue de 3 de
10 la siguiente muestra fue 7 de 10
luego tomamos otra muestra que también
resultó con 7 dulces amarillos así que
la gráfica mos aquí si seguimos tomando
muestras calculando la proporción
muestral de cada una e incluyendo la en
la gráfica tendremos una aproximación
mejor cada vez de la distribución
muestral de proporciones pero como
podemos caracterizar la verdadera
distribución muestral para la proporción
de la muestra cuál será la media y la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
muestral
podemos deducir ambas de lo que tenemos
aquí la media de la distribución
muestral de proporciones es igual a la
media de la variable aleatoria x
dividida entre n la media de x es n por
p y al dividirla entre n nos queda que
es igual a pp esto tiene sentido ya que
el valor esperado de la proporción
muestral es la proporción de dulces que
vemos realmente esto es un buen
indicador de que es un estimador in
sesgado ahora pensemos en la desviación
estándar de la proporción muestral
podemos considerarla como la desviación
estándar de la variable aleatoria
binomial x / m es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de n por p por 1 - p / m si
ponemos la m dentro del radical tenemos
que es igual a la raíz cuadrada de n por
p por 1 - p / n al cuadrado nos queda la
raíz cuadrada de p por 1 - p / n en esta
situación particular donde el parámetro
verdadero de la población es 0.6 cuál
será la desviación estándar para la
proporción muestral es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 0.6 por 0.4 entre 10 sacamos
la calculadora y escribimos 0.6 por 0.4
entre 10 es igual a cero punto 0 24 y
calculamos la raíz cuadrada de esto nos
da aproximadamente 0.15 lo escribimos
nos vemos en otro vídeo